welcome to film courage this is episode
162 I'm Karen warden and i'm david
brennan you can find our archives on
itunes movie garage and film Kurds com
today's guest is Lucas McNelly filmmaker
blogger and star of the crowdfunding
success story for the campaign a year
without rent and the man who backed it
up by volunteering his time on
independent film productions all over
the US and part of Europe for a solid
year and he lives to tell about it today
Lucas we want to thank you for coming
back here on my film curds and it's
great that had young once again the way
we're going to do this we're first going
to sort of talk about some current
things happening in the industry for
independent filmmakers we won't know
what we want to pick your brain a little
bit all right and then from there we're
going to sort of segue and do our best
to recap a year without rent and then
and then we'll kind of maybe come full
circle and kind of see where it's
brought to you today and then for those
of you listening if you want more Lucas
McNelly because you know we're going to
go right into the current state of
independent film here so if you want
sort of more of his backstory go ahead
and look up at the soul thumb Kurds
episode 99 um you know just visit the
film courage archives I there on folk
where's Connor iTunes you can find it
there and if you want even more of Lucas
we also have a video podcast update on a
year without rent that we did what about
a year ago and it's on our YouTube
channel yeah yeah exactly so this is
this is that next checkpoint where we
check in and see how the year went and I
but before before we get to all that
let's talk about some things you're very
close as far as we understand their
completing your feature film up country
and I just and I'm just curious once you
do finish it are you going to the film
festival circuit first um I don't know
I'm not a big fan of the film festival
circuit I think it's kind of the least
efficient way to get a film out to
audience members that we could probably
ever come up with you know I mean I
literally think you could be better
served burning dvds and handing them out
on the sidewalk
and submitting to festivals so maybe I
mean we'll probably send it to a couple
and see what you know see what happens
with it but we're not in any way
counting on that you know I'm glad
because you know I sort of have the same
opinion that that you know I just feel
film festivals you know they can be
great but I just feel in this current
state I feel like it's just dragging out
the process too long and and you're one
of the few other filmmakers I know
shares the same opinion that's why I
wanted to bring it up right off the bat
yeah I mean it's just like we couldn't
come up with the worst system if we
wanted to really I mean like I'm gonna
send them like a hundred dollars for
them to watch my movie and then decide
whether or not they're gonna show it and
it's not gonna sell because nothing
sells anymore so why like I don't
understand what the hundred dollars is
getting me you know maybe like a couple
reviews and a screening in front of 50
people maybe you know and that's if I
get in so it just seems really pointless
when I could just take it straight to
the audience directly but that's all
that middlemen well you had a
Nostradamus like prediction for 2012 and
you said one of the most successful
indie films of the year will be a film
that will skip the festival circuit
entirely do you still get this um yeah I
mean maybe not if not 2012 then I think
in the next couple years somebody will
do really well know this completely skip
the system I mean Greg remains pretty
much skipping the system already and it
doesn't seem to be hurting him very much
so you know I kind of have a Karl Marx
view of the film festival circuit in
that we're all going to sort of figure
out that we can throw down our chains
and throw down our tools and sort of
tape take it back over not now here's
the big dilemma you know it's easy to
say okay we're just going to bypass the
film festival circuit you know we're
going to find our own new way but but
what is what is that new net new way as
you see it I mean I think the system is
I think describes a big part of the
system I think it's going to iTunes and
it's going to youtube and its monetizing
on YouTube and things like that
you know if you can crowd fun to film
and then send those dvds to your backers
and then work your distribute costs your
iTunes costs into your budget then
you've got a film that's broken even
before you're finished and then you know
that's your that's your path to
sustainability and you've already got an
audience that's already invested their
time and energy and money into getting
making the film a reality hmm you know
cuz it's interesting you know cuz I've
been sort of i'm just gonna throw some
of my own thoughts here um you know I
look at I look at the studio system you
know and they have the money they have
the resources to do it their way you
know see the thing is they have these
huge massive films that they put a lot
of money into especially on the
marketing side and and they can also
afford to you know like they tease you
they promote the heck out of it but then
they also had the money to get it in
theaters across the country you know so
it's like you know independent
filmmakers we don't necessarily have the
power it's like we're gonna tease
audience I say here's my film and then
we're gonna go and we're going to take
it to a film festival here a film
festival there and it's like me while
people are just waiting and waiting and
waiting to see it and then on the other
end of the spectrum you have these
youtubers who are just producing content
every week and they're putting it out to
their audience and they're just
connecting with their audience every day
and then as it depended filmmakers we're
like stuck in the middle you know like
we're kind of reluctant to get our films
out to our audience quickly and we don't
have the money and resources that the
studio system does yeah I mean if I what
we have those were more nimble and we're
faster and we don't have their sort of
hierarchy and you know you know there's
sort of a lumbering giant the fact that
no one really you know if if I thought
if film of mine got into say South by
Southwest or Sundance I would literally
have the iTunes ready to start about ten
minutes after the first screening you
know and then we'll be turned on on
iTunes there because that's where you
have your biggest audience that's when
everybody's talking about your film you
know if beasts of the southern why
had been available on iTunes during
after that first screening of Sundance
it would have you know like every film
lover in the country would have bought
it pretty much sight unseen because it
was just that glowing sort of thing for
it we had an interesting conversation
before we started about YouTube as I was
saying that I don't regret being the age
that I am I just regret that YouTube
wasn't around when I was about 16 17 and
you had something to say about that it
was interesting take Lucas yeah I think
we're kind of in we were kind of born in
the wrong time if we hadn't born earlier
we could have been you know the Kevin
Smith richard linklater thing when you
could actually get into Sundance without
you know having to be you know
somebody's kid or do other things that
can get you arrested in some states and
you know in five years it's going to be
like the digital thing will probably
have that figured out by now by then and
then ten years that you know most so if
we were now say 23 we would be in like a
perfect spot to sort of catch that wave
or we could have caught the other way
now we're sort of stuck in the middle of
the waves and it's hard to you know it's
hard to talk yourself out of the old
system you know and just just coming
back to this other idea with itunes I
mean do you see where it really is that
easy you know cuz that's the whole thing
it's like it's easy to say like just get
your foam on iTunes or just go through
distribute but it's not necessarily
guarantee that we can get our films
right through that platform and on
iTunes you know and it's hard to see
what else where else we can turn at this
point I mean then you could I guess you
can go to dynamo you go to dystrophy you
could do um you do YouTube you can do
Votto I mean um belong block to block my
film one is as soon as the damn DVD is
done which should be in the next flight
week maybe for two I mean we're going to
turn it on photo and we're going to put
it online for free and their dvds will
be available through amazon so I mean
that's a way you can do it it's not I
don't think it's so hard to get the
movies out there it's just getting
people aware that the movies exist out
there lets you know k you gotta compete
with the Avengers and yeah which I don't
care about but other people do speaking
of
these that are out there what are the
best independent films that you've seen
in the last six months I um probably the
best thing I've seen in a really long
time was sought a city which I forget
the director's name but one of the
producers is working with Sean hack at
night on sanctity and that was I thought
a really fantastic film I saw it fly
away it was actually probably the best
movie I saw last year of any at any
level and I really liked Mary Marcy
something something alright that's
called um yeah i mean i just i got to
see very few movies last year so hmm you
know it's kind of I'm kind of behind I
have the copy of night before the
wedding that I saw it opened oh my car
some point you were discretion advised
yeah yeah you gotta break that went on I
think I think we gave that to him that
was that interactive sometime last year
so yeah so yeah like July or June hurts
exactly yeah coming up on it all runs
together what do you think the big thing
is that filmmakers are doing wrong in
terms of crowdfunding I mean when we
first started for a goodbye promise
crowdfunding was out there but it was
still relatively unheard of even with a
year without rent in the first campaign
but now it seems like everybody if you
go places you see people's cards and
lobbies Oh back my Kickstarter campaign
you see stuff on Craigslist hey wanna be
part of an indie production here's my
Kickstarter link what do you think the
biggest mistake is now that there's this
flood of crowdfunders out there I think
the two because now I somehow have ended
up consulting on these things and I
think the two things that I see a lot is
that people haven't done the
pre-production they haven't done their
homework and they're just not ready to
run a campaign you know and you look at
even some campaigns that are doing well
and you know in three minutes I can find
for things that are really big mistakes
like dumb dumb things in those campaigns
from people who have done campaigns
before you know so i think it's not
using the resources that are available
to make sure everything's really planned
out and then i think the other thing is
that we don't we don't try to come up
with stuff the specific to our campaign
it's sort of this plug and play DVD
poster digital download thing that's
really kind of dull and it has you know
there's nothing unique about it you know
and we chart we're trying to you know
convince people that we making this
great movie and no one really cares I
mean the most important thing is that
they're getting behind the filmmaker you
know goodbye promise did well because
people are getting behind you guys in
your film and that's why Gary's films do
well on Kickstarter and all of those
because people you know they don't care
about the movie it really they care
about helping a filmmaker get their
movie made do you think filmmakers are
getting lazy because it seems so
attainable we see these great you know
blue like jazz and all these campaigns
do so well and it just seems like BAM
you just press a button you launch your
campaign and it all floods to you do you
think we're getting too complacent I
think yes and no I mean there's more of
an awareness that it's hard so I think
really early there was this perception
that you just put it on there and there
are these magical elves on Kickstarter
who are just going back things and I
think everyone knows now that that's not
true but all of the you know all of the
information is kind of redundant and so
I think you know in a sense there's this
perception you know people come to me
they're like I'm going to raise thirty
thousand dollars but I'm like but you
have no following like no you have 50
Twitter followers and they're all
prostitutes you know are not real people
like what it is not you know there's
kind of a disconnect between knowing
what you can do in knowing you know what
you need I'm just curious I mean you say
you can quickly analyze the campaign and
you'll see just things that are
blatantly wrong I mean can you just yeah
that without and saying what the
campaign is plan just maybe give us you
know examples of what you're talking
about there I mean you'll see stuff like
you'll see the DVD at ten dollars you'll
see a poster at like forty dollars and
you just look at and you go they haven't
done the math here like a poster is I'm
really
the expensive thing to ship and it's a
big pain in the ass and so you're going
to get killed on your margins if the
posters really low and if the dvds
really low and it's stuff like you know
the image the the splash image on the
video doesn't have the name of your
project it just has an image from your
film you know or you have the wrong name
you have the wrong persons name
associated with the account so you know
instead of a video project by Joe Smith
it's a video project by such and such
productions or it's a video project by
like the producer of the film that no
one knows where you know maybe the
director is the name that people care
about you know it's just really like
stuff like that where you go for bloody
hell take five minutes you know and look
at this and go oh yeah it doesn't work
at all and the resources are there it's
not hard it's not you know it's not
brain surgery to figure out that how
much of dvds gonna cost you and how much
it's going to cost to ship and then to
go oh geez that's going to cost more
than I'm gonna make which is a mistake
we all make you know this mistake I made
so no I mean those are all great points
those are you give me that was that on
crowdfunding or no no I think that's it
right well we're gonna keep this
moving so just just real quick Lucas
we're just curious um in terms of like
you know social media platforms um apps
you know my baby for the iphone things
like that what are you using right now
that that has been really helpful really
effective um i use tweetdeck a lot i'm
more of a twitter person that a facebook
person i think google+ is a lot of
potential that no one's really you
tapping into and i'm not sure if it's
worth tapping into if no one else is
there on some level um I like the
storyboard composer app a lot that
Jonathan Houser put together and I'm
planning to use that on my next film at
least in some capacity and you know I
just a lot of photos and stuff like that
in terms of apps
is it about Twitter versus facebook that
you prefer I just I mean I I don't like
Facebook's sort of how they decide
what's in your feed and they keep trying
to turn my chat back on and I tries to
crazy Oh engine of the link still the
link sometimes don't work and it's just
really finicky and Twitter's got that
sort of more democratic method of you
know everything's in the feed it just
sort of flies through and I like the
shorter things and I like you know and
it really drives me crazy when I see
people's Twitter posts in their Facebook
feed late just nails on a chalkboard
Jimmy interesting okay Wi-Fi see another
hashtag I'm threat I one of these days
I'm just going to go and unfollow every
single person who has a hashtag on their
Facebook beef okay well switching gears
a little bit and rewinding I remember
back was it 2010 when you emailed us and
I remember the day because you and I
were taking a walk and went to the store
beautiful day and you said well this guy
Lucas is going to call and we're waiting
for your call and you called and you you
told us about this year without rent
thing we talk to you for a little bit
going back to that day did you envision
that this whole chain of events that
you've been through would happen that I
mean that was this picture of year
without rent is it yeah accurate from
what you've envisioned back in 2010 kind
of and I kind of knew from the beginning
that it wouldn't be what I envisioned I
thought I remember that I was actually
in Charlotte um visiting a friend um I
thought I really thought in my budget
and everything I thought I would start
so i started main and i thought i would
go from Boston to New York to philly to
Baltimore to DC and it would have done
more projects than I need what to do
with and all of that you know and that
would take like six months but within
six months I had already been to LA I
think twice you know and there was just
it was I was kind of shocking how hard
it was to get projects to work on you
know to be able to go no I'm going to
come in
for free and work on your film and it's
that's why would you not do that you
know and like people I knew didn't do it
you know people have different reasons
and whatever I just didn't anticipate
that being a stumbling block and that
sort of like was a budget killer in a
lot of ways because you know wandering
around Chicago for four days you know
that kind of starts to take up you know
time and resources and energy and all
that crap so other than that it was more
exhausting than I thought it would be um
I don't know why because I knew be
exhausting but I think maybe it's kind
of like a crowdfunding campaign you like
you know it's gonna be a lot of work but
you don't realize how much work it's
going to be until you're actually on day
12 you're like oh bloody hell this is a
lot of work mm you know do you think
that the word free scares people you
think they think what does he want here
maybe I think maybe my twitter feed
scares people more than the word free
what is it about your intervene I don't
you know I'll call you on your like
really quickly okay with a lot of four
other words and you know that was pretty
clear to everyone you know from the
get-go so I mean that's something that
it sort of takes and people have I think
there's a tendency to be really
secretive about your process and what's
going on and so some people just don't
want to open up you know that processed
outside scrutiny even if there is free
work involved with it and free publicity
and and everything else so you know I
mean there's that's part of it so I see
you know and look it's just to give us
the full scope I mean you did spend a
year you know traveling the country
heading over to Europe I mean all
together how many productions did you in
did I mean do you have a final tally I
had it I forgot what it was I should
have looked this up before I knew you
would ask me this I think it was close
to you can estimate was 40 to 50 things
like festivals and productions and stuff
like that I think I was somewhere in
there so
I went to 40 s something States four
countries and I forgot how many miles it
was a lot of miles I want to save like
40,000 miles mom uh-huh something like
that in of the 40 states and our yeah 40
states in the four countries that you've
been to which was the friendliest and
which was the most strict um I think
Berlin was the probably the friendliest
like Berlin was a lot of I stayed with a
guy in Berlin who I had never talked to
before ever like until I showed up at
his door I didn't even know his name was
until I got there you know um and
everyone in Berlin was really really
cool and they all spoke English which
was very helpful except for when they
were ordering me beer which they did in
German and then I would try to pay for
the beer and they were go oh no it's
already been paid for we did that that
was the German part all right great so I
mean Berlin was really cool um Seattle
was cool everybody in Seattle was really
great and I was up there for a couple
different productions Texas was really
cool um and then you know I think four
places I thought Chicago would be having
more projects like i like i said i spent
a couple days Chicago just couldn't find
projects to work on um yeah I mean then
it just because it comes down to people
or you know certain people are are
cooler than other people so okay we'll
leave it at that okay if Miss Manners
had a column on how to compose yourself
on a movie set in terms of etiquette
what would be some of the bullet points
it don't ask for cross services is it's
like the first thing or what oh yeah i
mean what you want to know where craft
services is because it's an important
thing to know I mean it's don't be in
the way and don't be a pain in the ass
and you know don't be that producer who
has to be behind the monitor even though
he has no function on set whatsoever you
know it's mostly just you know be cool
and like do your job and don't you know
make other people to your ship
are you and don't throw temper tantrum
and people it's not hard to get along
with film people like Phil people are
pretty cool and pretty easy going and
you know you get in a room grips and
it's pretty easy to fit in as long as
you're willing to carry ok you know
that's a big thick you know start start
moving things around you know well what
overall impact would you say that this
campaign it has much trying to say like
the impact or like you know how do you
see independent film now you know having
gone through this campaign I for me it's
a lot less fractured because you know
that's one thing to talk to someone
online on Twitter or whatever see their
movie and it's another thing to sleep on
their couch so you know and I I kind of
feel like you know it's going to sound
arrogant but I kind of feel like a
bicycle wheel we're like for the middle
the wheel and all these spokes are going
off where I have an actual direct
connection to people that like pretty
much all over so I mean that's a lot
more helpful for for me personally um
and you know I'd like to think that that
helps the community in some way and that
there's some like you guys are a common
element in a lot of the film community
and so if I can be a common element and
a couple other people then I think that
helps bring us all closer together
rather than just being a bunch of
different people who talk on Twitter all
day and do you have a new take on your
own life after this campaign and did
sort of the heavens open up and you saw
sort of your role in the world or it
made sense of your past or did you have
any kind of epiphanies that just like
aha this is why I'm here no but my back
really hurt okay really sleeping on
couch isn't sitting in my car a lot you
know I think I became a lot more sure of
my sort of viability in the film
community as you know as opposed to
because I think a lot of us we you know
we put on a good
game but we on some level we always feel
like we don't belong that we're sort of
the the idiot who sort of trying to
elbow their way in and so I don't really
feel like that anymore you know I feel
like I feel like someone who belongs in
the independent film community and and
has you know a niche and I mean maybe it
helps that I just have like a unique
experience that no one else has so you
know I mean I think that in that way
it's I feel a lot more confident a lot
more secure like sure of myself but it
you know like everything else my life is
still as screwed up as it was before I'm
happy I'm happy to hear you say that
little you know cos no I mean there's
many days r I feel like that I feel like
they have the same kind of thing i'm
still trying to elbow my way in I'd it
up right now yeah okay I'm glad to see
you reach a certain comfort love wife i
feel like i'm still trying to trying to
do that so um yeah and you know I I
spent less time thinking I should go
work in a bank or like you know go to
law school or some thing like that that
I would hate you know as much as my bank
account would would probably appreciate
it you know it just seems I feel I think
I told someone it's it's like in the
jungle book when they try to bring the
kid in from the wilderness and like you
know set him up in polite society I kind
of feel like that sometimes some people
are like you're gonna get like a day job
now like oh good god I hate that you
don't want to be you want to be fair old
boy yeah yeah farrell too yeah as long
as barrel boy connecting scotch no um I
know when we spoke to you last you know
you said a lot of a lot of productions
that you were participating on we're
being shot on DSLR cameras in the the
red cameras you know yeah what are the
changes in technology did you see over
the course from the very beginning days
of the campaign all the way through the
end I mean did you see a lot of changes
in technology or not so much not really
cuz i think the 5d two had just come out
when I started or sort of just come out
and then I don't think anyone liked the
scarlet I don't think the scarlet came
out until the very end of year without
rent like I just don't think there were
any big camera developments in that year
or anything that like hit the street so
you know I think it was just maybe to
begin month one it was a lot more
surprising to see a red than it was in
month ten you know because it was just
easier to get one and you know it seemed
the Alexa seemed like it was more of a
possibility near the end although I only
I think worked on one film with an Alexa
but it seemed more realistic at the end
of the campaign than it did at the
beginning of the campaign where before
you'd be like holy how did they get
one of those you know and so um let's
see I you know I was also wondering you
know did you have any sort of
heart-to-heart talks with filmmakers um
you know aside from just like sort of
what they were going through with
production me did you did you get a
chance to talk to some of these folks
and see kind of like um you know just
what challenges they're facing like with
our concern about over the course of the
year you know give it give us little
give us the inside scoop Lucas yeah I
mean I think we're all kind of concerned
about the same things we're concerned
about sustainability and we're concerned
about you know our processes and we're
all trying to sort of make our way in
the independent film world and so you
know the people that I I spent a lot of
time with you yeah you have a lot more
of those conversations like you know I'd
get drunk with 12 russell every it
seemed every couple weeks and you know
talk about stuff and I'd see Sean
Hackett a lot and so talk about stuff
with him and you know you just sort of
go through and it's you know in the
first maybe the first time you run into
someone you don't get that as much but
as you keep running into those people
over and over again you know I spent a
week in the car with uh with Victoria
Wescott and so we talked a lot I talked
a lot with Marty because I would keep
running into him and you know and it's a
lot of variants on the same theme it's
you know trying to
fight the impossible odds of getting a
film made and hoping that the film then
doesn't suck you know and then there no
one no one's really sure we're there no
one's really comfortable where they want
to live and you know the people in LA
don't want to be in la anymore the
people who aren't in la want to be in LA
the only people who seem to be happier
than people in Brooklyn but nobody wants
to talk to most people in Brooklyn
they're just insufferable sometimes so
other than Todd critical Todd who's in
Brooklyn and is real cool yeah a lot of
the people just like oh shut up I don't
care about Brooklyn well enter in terms
of process you talked about no talking
with other people about their process
for your process where the year without
rent what would you keep the same and
what would you change looking back are
we assuming I have more money here in
assuming I have the same amount of money
oh I would say the same and in in the
current reality that is Lucas McNally's
life right now men um I think it would
be easier in that I would know more
people and it would maybe you know I
kind of spent the first like two or
three months of the campaign trying to
explain to people what the hell I was
doing and you know and you always want
to be sort of more organized and stuff
like that and maybe I probably could
have put less less fewer things in my
car but then there wasn't really any
where else to put them so they kind of
ended up being stuck in the car it would
have been really nice to have like a
white panel van that I could have slept
in as you know in the middle of Montana
as opposed to sleeping you know in a
hotel that would help the budget um but
you know it was kind of always designed
as one of those projects where i was
going to kind of have to figure it out
as I went along and do the best I could
with you know the resources at hand at
the moment so you know you figure out
things as you go along and you just sort
of once you after a while I'd start to
get the rhythm of it down and that
seemed to help and you know you just get
better taking photos and you just get
more comfortable on sets and stuff like
that with your Soto's or X
oh thank you excellent young and I
remember to when you would come to LA
for one of our Interactive's and we
remember we talked to my car and it was
like late at night in the downtown
independent parking lot I think you said
at some point that you were tired and
that you almost wish you could have just
taken a break for like two weeks and
just kind of watch movies and ben and
eat pizza so what are you don't recharge
I know now it's a different story but
what were you doing then to recharge and
sort of have some Lucas time I wasn't
really is the part of the problem like I
think I got that time in the car is what
I sort of started to do is sort of
figure out that that was going to have
to be where I would recharge which is a
really exhausting way to recharge when
you're driving 500 miles you know across
Kansas or whatever but um you know I
think I became more comfortable the idea
of like staying in a hotel room when I
needed to and it's one of those things
where the budget doesn't it doesn't make
sense for the budget but it's it's
really helpful for just resting and
getting some sleep and there's something
that's kind of exhausting about as great
as it is to be on someone's couch
there's something kind of exhausting
about you know meeting someone and
sleeping on their couch and then you
know you want to you want to be a good
guest and you know you're they want they
have questions and they you know they
want to talk to you about this weird
thing you're doing and sometimes you
don't want to talk to anybody about
anything and you want to you know watch
SportsCenter for an hour so you try to
find ways to do that and you know as you
would get you would get to places like
you know I would stay I stay with a
friend in Austin for a couple days and
I'd really do very much I just sort of
caught up on stuff and that was nice
because then it was you know you sort of
just go you know what the projects
aren't going to be here for these four
days so I'm not going to kill myself to
look for 1 i'm just come out you know
I've got a couch the night and sleep
bottoms go sleep on it and try to get
some sleep forgive me I'm still thinking
about just two weeks of eating pizza and
watching movies you know so it's tough
yes I had one day I was I because I
finished in LA and I blew back to where
my car was and I was literally there a
day when Sean akka calls mean he's like
hey you want to produce my next movie I
was like ah alright so I you know
haven't even I kind of had trying to
recover sort of but not really oh now
tell us you know what was there sort of
a breaking point you know like here you
are you know the nonstop just you know
for this over the duration of the entire
year was their breaking point regions
like you know what this isn't completely
what I signed up for and this is you
know I'm just gonna I'm gonna stop right
here i'm heading back to main i'm
heading back to these column heading
home no more was there a meltdown on
camera got on camera damn um i had an
early thing yeah i mean i'd have a
couple where i would I had one kind of
in Denver and then I had one in
Pennsylvania when like three or four
campaigns in a row bail like projects
bailed on me within like a week and I
still haven't heard back from one of
those projects like literally the last
email i sent them was which of these
three flights should i get on to come
work on your movie and that's the last
thing i've ever heard from these people
so you know I mean that's you just sort
of it you're like this is not worth it
this is stupid i have a lot of other
things I could be doing with my time and
you know you get on sets were like the
director doesn't know who you are or
what you're doing or why you're there
and doesn't care and you know that is
mad at you for something that you've
done on every movie you've worked on and
you're like seriously do why am I here
why did I Drive 800 miles to come work
on this movie if you're not going to
take 20 minutes to read to like look at
the blog and go oh so this is what this
is
you know and you just get to that where
you just get really fed up with people
and you're like this is this is
ridiculous i'm like i have my own movies
I want to make I'm just really sick of
all of this and I think maybe my closest
meltdown was um after I was done I was
supposed to go to DIY days and you know
it's money being tight I really didn't
want to drive anywhere so I was like
well take one of these Greyhound express
buses and it was like an eight hour bus
ride and I literally had a panic attack
on a Greyhound bus and one minute before
the bus left for New York City I said
the hell with it I'm done I got off the
bus and you know they were like well we
can't refund your ticket and I said yeah
I don't care like i would pay two
hundred dollars right now to not be on
this bus and I think wonder said it was
post-traumatic stress disorder or
something but it seems excessive you
know you just get the part you're like I
ya know oh thank you for sharing that
Lucas you know and and we just want to
take this this moment here to dis
emphasize and commend you for sticking
this thing out from start to finish you
know it's one thing it's a sort of like
say I'm going to do this but um you know
we just really commend you and respect
and admire that you were able to thrust
yourself into this and you know sort of
no man lifestyle and sticking with it
and and and just you know sharing as
much information as you know as many of
these projects that you did over the
course of this year yeah and i'm still
like way behind catching up because once
it finished there was like a month and a
half where I even want to think about it
anymore so there's I probably got I
don't like 20 blog posts left to right
and I still have to send out a bunch
purse and everything but you just I said
that point I was like I can't I just
can't think about this at all right now
so I started you know working on some
other stuff and and trying to catch up
on TV shows that i had been able to
watch but not thankfully mad men waited
until i was done to restart their season
so i thought that was really nice of
them
I didn't fit too far behind on mad men
at least you know and on and on those
low days what kept you motivated what
kept you saying you know what I am going
to stick this out and I'm gonna make it
to the next day you know I'm just really
stubborn I think and I remember I was in
Maine for let's say Christmas because
who remembers um and you know it like
Christmas I was in Maine for Christmas
for like two weeks because December is
dead and there's nothing going on and I
kind of knew that going in and I had
after new years I had a month and a half
left and you know there were some people
who thought I was already done because
they figured it was the calendar year
and that was kind of one of those points
or I was like you know I really easily
stop right now and you know you I just
would keep telling myself I remember
telling my mother this I was like if I
can get through this thing and survive
it it will be the thing that leads my
bio for like ten years but if I quit
that it will be you know it will
diminish the entire thing so I just have
to survive the string however I managed
to do that and get to the finish line
and then you know and then I can do
nothing for a period of time or whatever
so it was just then it was a question of
an end so like the last month and a half
was really like you know I was there was
i was talking to people in Boston and
they were you know playing playing phone
tag with but I couldn't get him on the
phone and so then I just hit appointment
with that I was like how the hell that
I'm going to Marty's house for like four
days or however long i was in Marty's
house I was like you know what these
guys unless they call me back screw it I
don't care you know cuz you just hit a
break you hit that breaking point well
it's great that you saw that bigger
picture because we know from I mean
things it's like stuff would be going
well for you know a certain system and
then
this robot comes and it's so easy to get
frustrated and mad and and give up but
on the flip side I had a lot of great
things happen in terms of you had
several people who wanted you to speak
on panels and you know I mean they were
in that group but I mean you had some
people in Germany was it Wolfgang uh
yeah Wolfgang had me speak in Berlin at
a crowdfunding thing that was really
cool and a spoke couple times in LA and
you know I think that was maybe one of
the things that kept me going was
whenever I would start gettin down like
someone would sort of go something would
happen like that where like I had that
hater show up and like the really bad
did I was I remember driving through
Montana and so there's like no cell
phone coverage in Montana I get to
Seattle and someone's like what the hell
is going on with your article and I'm
like I no idea what you're talking about
and so then Sheree cameras like don't
read it it's not worth it and you know
and there was just this big uproar and
then literally like that day I got an
email from like a really well-known
director saying I think what you're
doing is really cool blah blah and you
know that really helped and so whenever
would get really bad you know there
would be someone who would say oh no
this is I really love what you're doing
this is really great you know keep it up
and that kind of was the sort of thing
that would get you that would get me
going for a little bit longer you know
every every sort of time it would sort
of step up in its notoriety would it
would sort of be a good way for me to go
well I have to keep going now because of
this a business well in looking back on
all that of all the chaos and people
flaking out or or being non
communicative what was your biggest
surprise about people about planning
things about having things fall apart
you know either good or bad what was the
biggest takeaway that you got from that
you know I think probably how just very
cool people are about you know and I'm
like you know the people who flake and
our kind of
get all the publicity but there's that
was a really small minority of the
people who I encountered and the vast
majority of them were very very cool
like Barry like probably ninety five
percent of the people I met were awesome
you know I had a lot of trouble buying
my own drinks you know stuff like that
and you know if I was near somewhere
people go you totally stay here total of
blah and everyone was really
accommodating and really helpful with
this really strange thing that was sort
of thrust upon that I sort of thrust
upon everybody and you know it was that
was kind of overwhelming and when
Victoria and Marty did the campaign to
keep going that was really an
overwhelming thing because you know your
sort of out on your own and sometimes
you feel like you're sort of shouting
into the wind and then to have everyone
rally around something like that was
really awesome and so would you do it
again if this if you're without read to
you know no probably not no um really
what I've been telling people is I'm I
don't for one second regret doing it but
I don't know that I would do it again
because it's just so overwhelming in
every way and you know I would
definitely encourage people to do it in
some capacity you know do a couple
months do whatever I mean you can't beat
it you see the country you get to meet a
lot of people you know you it's this
great networking on steroids but you
know I think it's one of those things
that you can do once and then it's just
you know because i have i have my own
films that I want to make and you can
only be a production assistant for so
long before you're ready to strangle
somebody you know you can always spend
so much time in your car before you know
your back starts to get out I think it's
great though that you saw that bigger
picture that this will lead your bio for
10 plus years I mean look at Morgan
Spurlock was super sadly I mean I'm sure
he I know he suffered health problems
because of it but it basically throws
his career and then when we saw you in
Connecticut just recently at the
Quinnipiac crowdfunding panel we asked
you but we want to hear it again what do
people back home say you know you run
into people in Maine and they see you at
the store or whatever that are you still
doing that that rent thing or what I
mean what are they yeah they're all kind
of confused because it's a very fishing
heavy community and so there's not a lot
of film there um but they're all very
cool you know they'll see me randomly in
town and it's gotten important he'll
just go oh for some reason Lucas is in
Maine all right sure why not so you know
they're all kind of you know they're
more comfortable with it than they were
at the beginning but it's everyone's
kind of confused and sort of like oh
great that's good how's that going you
know it's not as bad as when i was at
DIY days last year and i was literally
like three weeks in and I was telling
this one of the speakers at DIY days who
I won't name because for obvious reasons
and he sort of looked at me like you're
gonna do that yeah okay sure and it was
very condescending in the very like what
an moment and so that was kind
of one of the things that I would think
of when it would go badly it was kind of
you know the you I'm gonna do this
because I'm stubborn up not sure if I'm
allowed to curse down on the new format
am I um yeah why not well did you set me
look forward him your filmmaker magazine
posts and just say hey just thought you
might be interested in this no cuz he
seemed like he was barely listening so I
he's even gonna remember all right you
know but I remember telling the story on
Twitter like during the second year
without red campaign and a lot of people
were like latta guys totally an
and so and did you never ran into him
again that was
one time no I haven't even heard his
name sense so you know that shows you
how much how important is or how viable
is this panel is pretty crap too so
maybe you just an idiot how you know we
know you did some filming throughout the
campaign as well you know so not only
were you helping on these productions
but we know there's a lot of footage
that you were able to grab are we going
to see a year without rent documentary I
you know we believe that you handed off
the footage to another film a gallery is
there anything going on with that I
handed the footage off to John Yost who
writes the micro budget conversation for
filmmaker okay head so he has got
somebody and I literally you know I
never said there was gonna be a
documentary but everyone sort of assumed
there would be so that I kind of got
stuck with this documentary I didn't
want to make because I'm over it you
know I don't want to look at anymore so
I pretty much just handed it off to him
and I said you know here's how I sort of
see it is I hand the footage over and
then you let me know when it's done and
I'll show up at the premiere and I don't
really want any creative control over it
or anything like that and I'm like if
you can find a filmmaker who thinks I'm
idiot pick him and you know make the
documentary about how much of a failure
it was if you can you know if you can
find someone who's willing to do that
and one to put in that much time and
effort so I think his plan is is really
hard to film yourself when you're on a
film set you know so I think this plan
is he's going to interview a bunch of
people and then he's going to on my next
film which is going to have I think is
gonna have a lot of year without rent
alumni working on it he's going to
follow that production as we shoot that
which will probably be this summer and
that's kind of going to create like sort
of a lot of the narrative I guess it is
documentary as I understand it and I
mean did you film a lot of yourself you
know like I have a go I had a GoPro so
there's some footage of me you know
wandering around and then I would
randomly get the camera to other people
sometimes
and they would take pictures and video
the video is more of a you know I was
sort of shooting more for like a three
minute web serial sort of format of oh
this is this thing that this grip is
doing where they're taking a plunger
sticking it on a camera and so more of
an educational aspect than you know
geared towards a actual documentary and
it was just I just found really quickly
that it was much much easier to take
pictures than it was take video you know
while you're actually trying to work
because you can sort of strap the camera
to your back and then sort of put on
much as opposed to trying to hold it and
frame up a shot and hold focus and all
that stuff and the pictures were just
much more effective people were just
responding so much better to the
pictures than the video that you know
you sort of adapt on the fly and again
your pictures are beautiful but thank
you that helps to the picture look
better yeah yeah yeah and you know I
believe where we left off last time is
you know at the last checkpoint you were
hoping that that sponsorship would come
in you know as you completed the year
man did you ever have any success with
that like when them happening with sort
of pursuing sponsorship to come on board
for that for that second half of the
year no nothing really came of that you
know we pursued it and we talked to some
people and you know it just didn't
happen although ironically it might have
been one of the people I guess we're
talking to my husband now hmm with
something um but we'll see you know um
yeah nothing really some conversations
but nothing really came through in terms
of actual you know being an actual skill
being an actual sponsor of it but you
know my worry was just that I wouldn't
have enough like budget to get through
it and to head to keep being able to pay
for gas so I wasn't super concerned with
that is like I didn't really care if I I
think I told you guys at one point if I
fully expect to end this with the dollar
in my pocket so you know I wasn't really
looking to get rich on it and have you
know like Southwest sponsored
the whole project is give me free
flights for life or something like that
I was like you know as long as I can
survive this thing that that's my
priority well reminds me of what Connor
weeks 10 miles per hour didn't all these
sponsors kind of jump on at the last
moment right as he was sort of crossing
the finish line on the site way there
yeah it seems like that and I'm
wondering um you know how there been any
filmmakers that have sort of asked you
to or are willing to carry the torch or
like you know what Lucas donut in this
campaign we just want you to do one more
on us kind of getting I yeah there were
a couple projects that sort of worst
like oh can you come do this one unlike
a kind of dumb I did Matson's film
Matson's film was supposed to be the
last one bruiser and I got pushed back a
couple weeks so I did that one and i was
completely wiped i literally fell asleep
doing a light guy during a take you know
um because i had nothing left in the
tanks so i've had a couple people have
been like oh you know i just heard about
the projects for the Grateful up you
know would you want to do it and I just
tell people that the free portion of a
year without rent is over and there
everyone is very understanding of that
and not that really ends a conversation
pretty quickly funny oh that's not free
and conversations know what's really so
is that you know and then what about
other filmmakers like approaching you
was saying okay Lucas you know I
actually want to do this myself I mean
have you been solicited in that manner
where someone wants to yeah i think
marty lane was thinking about it and i
think he should do it but i don't know
how he's gonna fit on these couches
because he's just really tall and some
of these couches are pretty short so you
know and i think people have asked you
know how would i respond to someone
doing it and i think you know I think
it'd be great you know I'll give them
the you know passwords and the rolodex
as it were and you know they can go to
town I mean I don't think you know I
think if someone right out of film
school I think were to do it it would be
a really great investment
their time and you know experienced to
do that and I don't think I think
someone asked me if I thought it would
diminish what I did and I don't think it
would I just I think it would maybe even
like enhance it and that it would be
something that sort of keeps going I
think Shawn had had tried to talk
someone into doing it instead of film
school but I don't know if he was
successful with that so no no Steve Jobs
secrecy you would hand over the keys and
you'd be fine with it and yes okay
that's cool yeah it's a it was the whole
process was really open source like all
of the photos and video that I took at
the end of each production I would just
copy all of the files over to their hard
drive and you know you can see them in a
lot of Kickstarter campaigns you can
sort of you know if you look closely
you'll see a lot of the year without
rent credit watermark thing on a lot of
Kickstarter images and videos and stuff
like that so I mean it was really you
know the goal was to get the filmmakers
as much help as you could so you know
giving them access to videos and photos
and all of that stuff was part of was
part of that and I think they were least
there was at least one film that
actually used my camera to shoot a scene
I think so it was there you know my goal
was to make whatever they needed to make
their life as easy as possible because
I've been in that situation where you're
you know you have no money to finish
this film and literally everything helps
and this was the t2i as you were using
yeah yeah the g2i and I kept meaning to
get another lens but I never did I got
the like had two kittens the whole time
Wow look if you actually got another one
but I didn't want to like carry around
like four different lenses and because I
literally had to operate out of a
backpack that had for hard drives in it
and a computer and one are your back
hurt yeah computers & cables a camera uh
an audio recorder of microphone
batteries a couple other things so the
bag was really full and it would always
get a really interesting look going
through airport security I'm sure it
always get pulled and it would they
would be like oh we're gonna check your
m.i.a I go check back all right
interesting um so where are you putting
your time now what's the rest of
2012-2013 looking like for you um while
doing these crowdfunding campaign
consulting things because I just keep
getting emails and so I figured I that
was as good a way to make money as any
um and so that's been really kind of
cool and you know it's it's a nice
experience to be able to kind of keep
the ethos of a year without rent where
the goal is to make people you know make
it possible people to get their movies
made so you know to be able to help them
crowd fund it which is something I've
been lucky enough to have some success
with is really you know it's nice end um
so there's that and then I'm producing
Sean Hackett's next film on one of the
producers on that and then I'll probably
direct a film this summer that Marty
laying and Damien dighton wrote that i
did a pass on and then i think i'm
producing a movie in vegas maybe this
fall I think we'll say it wasn't there
was this a crowd fund enough you know
you have another executive producer
credit on on a current project what is
what is that project uh-oh the undrawn
yeah the bundle of brothers did a web
series and that was that ended up being
like the very last thing in a year
without red where I help them set up the
crowdfunding their crowdfunding campaign
and that sort of was what gave me the
idea that you know I should probably do
that more so they you know they needed
some help setting it up and everything
so I have some of that and for instance
um you know you producing you know beat
you being one of the producers on Sean
Hackett's film you know what kind of
so you're going to be doing how are you
going to be helping that production I'm
going to be on 7 i'm in the movie i'm
guessing because there's a character in
the movie called Lucas who has a camera
so I I think that's me I haven't heard
me other casting rumors about that role
so I'm assuming that I'm involved with
that so he sort of got a brain trust of
a couple people who are producing that
and he's casting it right now and so I'm
helping with the crowdfunding campaign
we're gonna do and setting all that up
and then just you know onset putting out
fires and getting drunk with the cast
you know your classic producing things I
guess you know and what's right to hear
you talking about their me you're
talking about you know collaborating
with Sean Hackett you know you've also
mentioned Marty Lane collaborating there
you've mentioned on your own on your own
project I'll there's going to be a lot
of year without rent sort of alumni
coming together is that is that do you
see a lot more of this sort of thing
happening you know because it really you
know it's really sort of that boosted
independent film needs in these sort of
that level of collaboration just love to
get your thoughts on that yeah I mean
that's one of the things that we can do
is sort of our you know captain planet
our powers combined thing where we can
sort of combine all our resources and
and get things accomplished you know it
does us no good to you know jealously
guard all of our secrets and sort of be
in these cliques you know so if we can
get you know this person from here and
you know then get pull everyone together
into one production it's so much more
effective than just you know pulling a
bunch of people out of your at it like
that because any weapon opportunity to
get the best people and it's just you
know I mean you get people you're more
comfortable with and you end up with
better movies so it seems stupid not to
you know from my perspective and then
just in terms of getting the alumni to
do
my next film it's it's a real easy sell
cuz I go remember when that time when i
worked on your movie for free well guess
what i'm going to call in that favor now
so um we're gonna fly you here and it
would be great you'll have fun oh nice
well for those of you listening you can
find Lucas on Twitter at El McNally and
you can see all of his work at a year
without rent calm and also on film
courage calm and stay tuned for his
upcoming feature film up country yeah
Lucas Lucas it was great seeing you in
Connecticut with marty was nice I fun
hanging with you there and we have some
video that will be unleashing soon and
we're very excited to get that out there
but I'm getting very limited it was nice
having pizza with you at Yale yes even
though we had to watch the Red Sox
collapse during the meal would you
stopped yeah I returned home that night
my mom is actually a Red Sox fan and she
stopped watching the game so she she
thought the red sox had won that game
and then I told the doctor I don't think
they won and she's like what did she got
she got really upset it was awful it was
really terrible Lucas thank you again
for joining us on All Stars it's my
pleasure thank you guys for all your
help because I don't think without you
well obviously without you guys I don't
it wouldn't have been funded in the
first place so you know that was that
was really awesome and you guys do great
stuff for the community so well thank
you well I think some you're so
resourceful that somehow somehow you
would have done something something
would have no I just get you there for a
while Kickstarter elf would have come
out and done something I don't know yeah
the whole flogger kicks that route yeah
yeah so I mean well thank you lucas we
appreciate that but really I mean youth
you've carried this torch and and I
don't know if a lot of people could have
done it because I'm sure it was very
exhausting physically emotionally
spiritually financially so but I mean I
I think that if that's what it took that
stubbornness that's great that you use
that and carried you through yeah
so that's one thing else manners are is
stubborn 7 okay we're very stuck and we
don't like people telling us what we can
do and what we can do and we don't like
people from where Yankee bins those are
really the things we don't like okay
sort of the short list yeah neither the
day I think I think Karen I if we had
been in your shoes I wonder I wonder if
it would have lasted more than a month
on on the road traveling all about you
know Victor Victoria Road with me for a
week and she was ready to quit like four
hours in she was like this is ridiculous
it's all those like we would done
anything yet we're just driving through
Washington State this is the easy part